can you start a YouTube channel as a
hobby and have fun in 2024 of course but
can you start a profitable Channel yes
and it was Yahoo finance that revealed
that the Creator economy and Creator
economy
businesses are the fastest growing small
business type right now so this is
exciting because you could in 2024 what
are you trying to achieve do you want to
open up a coffee shop do you want to
open up a flower shop do you want to
rent some commercial space do you want
to be a franchiser a franchisee of a
Subway or these different things you
could do or do you want to start a
Creator business well if you're
listening to this video podcast then
you're you're thinking about getting
into YouTube and a quick tip there is I
think one of the most powerful ways you
can start YouTube is with a business
mindset not many start they think oh
it's going to be a side hustle it's
going to be a hobby fine but Yahoo
finance said this is the fastest growing
business type and I found that by
shifting your mindset from kind of like
oh I'm just dabbling in a hobby to I
want to dominate this as a business
forces you to think a little bit
different okay what skills do I need how
how could I approach this strategically
how could I approach this more
intentionally and so this is the fastest
growing small business type and that is
continuing into
2024 that speaks to the opportunity of
starting and growing but also the
opportunity of making money but probably
the most significant recent youTube stat
That Shook Me To The Core was Goldman
Sachs research
revealing that over the next 3 to four
years the creater economy is going to
double and be a half a trillion dollar
industry so let's unpack that first of
all right now they revealed and this is
Wall Street people that are smarter than
me smarter than us here we are sitting
in Las Vegas in our video podcast studio
uh you're pretty brilliant I'm I'm glad
to be getting to be here with you but I
mean ultimately you know we're sitting
here these are analyst Financial
analysts looking at Big Data looking at
numbers looking at all this different
stuff so they have evaluated that the
crator economy currently is evaluated at
$250 billion it's kind of one way of
looking at how much money is in the
system you know if you apply this to a
different industry they might say how
much how much money is in restaurants
Topline like how much money is in um
network marketing it's this big of an
industry So currently the Creator
economy is a $250 billion industry
that's a massive number and if you had
just a tiny piece of that the
practicality of earning an extra 10
grand a year or $55,000 a year or
whatever is is more practical than
people realize but okay it's 250 right
now and what Goldman Sachs research is
looking at based on all economic factors
and things we're look in this
environment I mean people sometimes we
get Doom and Gloom oh is it a recession
what's going to happen next and of
course different things can happen but
they look at the market they look at
what's happening they look at the Trends
they say okay that's going to double in
the next four
years the reason this is so insane is
because as you mentioned I've been on
YouTube 17 years YouTube's only existed
for I think 19 2005 so you go 2005 to
2014 that's 19 years I started my first
channel for uh my local church in a
small town an hour north of Seattle
called Marysville Washington it was a
terrible Channel I mean it was fine
because it was for a church but the in
these days you had a 15-minute upload
limit no custom thumbnails we were doing
everything wrong our technology was
inferior all this different stuff but I
just have had the privilege of being in
the game a long time personally growing
channels helping others grow if I'm
understanding Goldman Sachs research
correctly they're saying this I've
watched the whole thing from start to
now grow for the last 19 years from 2005
and and when did the creator economy
start well it started to be fair it's
not just YouTube this would be the other
social platforms when did it start it
started whenever the first platform
probably YouTube you had YouTube
Facebook came a little bit later now X
then eventually Instagram those are kind
of being of course the big ones YouTube
by far and Facebook I think you know
maybe the biggest in terms of Money
YouTube pays the most as far as crators
okay great so it has taken from 2005
until
2024 that long for the crater economy to
become worth $250 billion for that much
money to be in the system and it's crazy
now when we think about that we think
about our own experience we've generated
millions of dollars in our company from
21 different income streams great okay
but what about people listening to this
and other people and they've probably
watched YouTubers get famous that are
entertaining education YouTubers doing
doing DIY and Etsy making money we get
to see our students results so we see
behind the scenes and see people making
a couple Grand a month a few hundred
dolls a month from affiliate marketing
we see how much money is in the system
of e-commerce and affiliate marketing
just you make a video and recommend
jeans or fashion or supplements or
whatever and how much money is there
okay so it's taken 19 years for this
whole thing to be valued at $250 billion
and Goldman Sachs research says all
that's happened in the last 19 years is
doubling in the next four I that's the
point I'm trying to get across massive
acceleration is it too late it's just
getting started and actually it's maybe
one of the best times to start if you
enjoy this podcast and are ready for
some deep dive YouTube strategy just go
to think masterclass.com to get access
to my 1hour on demand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com